hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry
it's Halloween people so we thought we'd
do a little fun compilation video for
you guys we didn't do the compilation of
course we're just gonna react to it
we're gonna we're gonna do face things
it's such hard work what we gotta do it
it is from thug life videos Halloween
thug life compilation
I love thug life yeah as a general idea
but I should do a compilation you know
what animal thug compilation animals
coming on people known imagine that runs
by Lord oh hi that was Jesus on the
audience inside of the zoo no he's find
that a little bit creepy to just a watch
like like as a thing that somebody might
search on the internet why is that
creepy compilations are awesome
especially when it's my importance are
[ __ ] awesome you seen a say Kyra's
compilation who she just had many a guy
come on her who at asa Akira NASA Kara
Harley not pronounce it probably ASA
it's probably ASA it's a hot-ass asian
chick oh cool yeah really hot really
yeah okay like after you leave us notice
every day holy [ __ ] they post daily who
does that
happy Halloween to everybody out there
we're having a good day and thanks for
watching and we'll get started with this
first experiment and it's the exploding
pumpkin what happens as soon as I put
the secret ingredient and I add water a
reaction occurs we're going to let that
build up on the inside okay so much so
that whenever I put this in the back it
should go kaboom
okay the eyes the nose the mouth should
come out first are you ready yeah I'm
ready are you sure I think so tonight
onto the tip he was going down on her
that's what was happening right I think
you just did something
who likes Halloween candy well we're
gonna replace candy with some healthy
Halloween treats today these are called
veggie Fruit Chews guys kids I got
something to tell you
ate all your home candy wow that was
real that's bad parenting yeah you don't
sneak another person my Barbara class
you make us no more hourglass
these are tofu ghost mellows blank
writing down b12 b12 is like the best
treat you can go on out of it I'm
thinking work that every post yo what
the [ __ ]
yeah what they're doing now just cutting
right through you see how it goes right
and they're delicious healthy cupcake
good stuff is good stuff and it's
disgusting Jana the middle of the
reaction
there is this one time I remember going
down I was I don't know how to ride a
bike yes I know hard for you to believe
I look like a bike rider right and then
one time I was learning how to do it and
my friend Brandi you know Brandon okay
we lives in this place called Valencia
which is a place where rich people live
- at the top of the hill and then I was
like getting down how to ride a bike and
then I started going downhill we wanted
to get some Lunchables you know when
they had the hotdog hammered or
Lunchables those were [ __ ] is
delicious what the [ __ ] did you do
Lunchables it was like bring that [ __ ]
back cuz the big four is the hot dog
hamburger the pizza and the nachos Oh
nacho said the cheese miss notable salsa
but everybody's [ __ ] cheese we're
going downhill and
one of those lights on the street what
happened was gravity decided to be very
interesting tonight
the handles turned went down and I
literally didn't go like this I went
like up and straight down onto the bar
handles with my crotch and I had a nasty
bruise and I had to crawl to the
sidewalk what and I ran it was like are
you okay
and then out and then I was like Brandon
I'd just get the Lunchables and come
back go on without just bring me back a
hot so I laid on the sidewalk for about
twenty minutes because the Lunchables is
gonna close at Albertson's in about 20
minutes so he had to go on a happen like
how is that even possible
I don't know I'd like to think the devil
or God was playing a trick on me one of
those makes more sense than the one one
of those makes sense the other one opens
up some very interesting question you
know what's funny a lot of these
reactions that what we were reacting to
people good oh my god and one of the
common ones was like they would sort of
a punch yeah yeah yeah and I think if
you're gonna have a reflex of getting
scared and you throw a punch good idea I
wouldn't want to actually have this guy
like go through a maze like Ian
Universal or something yeah that kind of
reflex makes our lives very very
different yeah I understand that however
if you get scare in real life sometimes
throwing a good punch is what's needed
what if a serial killer comes up to you
what if a woman with like perfect ABS
huge tits blonde hair juicy ass decides
to come up behind you and grab your
crotch you got to punch that [ __ ] for
sexual harassment backwards coming from
you I mean I think there's probably a
way to resolve that without resorting to
physical violence yeah fair hey I gotta
say to you don't punch anybody at a
haunted house I gotta say to have seen
it like several compilation videos I
don't really do them because there's not
much to talk about afterwards yeah no I
mean you see a lot of insight a lot of
channels I do reactions only react and
don't really provide commentary
afterwards well what do we do now the
video is still going what were we
supposed to talk
apparently we can try to verbalize more
our thoughts you know because you can't
get all the thoughts of a reaction in
just watching someone react to a video
you want to hear the discussion but I
can't think and react to the same I know
yes it's tough it's hard I mean
different by now if we were like every
other reaction channel we just say
subscribe already yeah subscribe already
I do want to say that I've seen several
compilation videos these guys love live
videos tend to get me though like they
tend to get other selections are pretty
good they're not too long and they're
their selections of things are like it's
more than just you know what I hate is
watching like these vine compilations
like we were watching a Breaking Bad
vine compilation' and it's just like
okay we get it you throw over some
famous song and it's like it doesn't
make it cool or funny if you do that
yeah some of them are just sort of like
here is a mishmash of the same few clips
set to music yeah and then it's just the
same clips in different songs and you're
like what it's really cool how they know
how to choose good clips you know like a
punch line at the end or they are the
definitive punch line with their thug
life break out thing yeah their little
viral videos yeah and they're great at
putting these together and I like the
thug life aspect they have - them -
these guys are good these guys are
really good gun thug life yeah you guys
make me want to be a thug give a bear
hug my dick I tug on it all night long
want to give it a hug maybe jerk off on
the rug lug nuts [ __ ] a girl in those
hot butts wait wait wait hold on why she
have more than one but she has more than
one but because she cut it into four
pieces
Jesus wouldn't she just leave this alone
but a girl has to care so much about her
image let's get real real courage to go
after something that means a lot more
instead of impersonating yourself as a
stupid dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I to
here oh no you almost got
to some degree I know but then I decided
I guess on the use of gangster rap don't
be a massage yeah so if you guys are new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Gerry's
playlists on this channel its reasons to
Gerry if you want to get his movie
reviews and Dan cast stubs if you wanna
hear his podcast that he co-hosts with a
guy named Aaron his uh he's a talker
that one and you could follow us on
social networks good luck finding us
just type in the real rejects who knows
maybe we'll come up with do a shout out
Isak Dale Sutherland with Southard I'm
sorry this guy sent multiple messages
I'm just gonna read the last one love
the vids and keep up man the comedy and
the way you conversate with guests and
throw them off is great oh [ __ ] oh dude
Issac Dale Southard more likes out hard
yeah you are a cunning linguist I am a
master debater well done Lord puns award
puns are fun when you put your penis in
the buttons isaac tail um dude thank you
so much my friend you know the fact that
you love us makes me love you i'm
thinking leaving my girlfriend for you
my friend
my girlfriend has not sexually satisfied
me for a day now and well i was really
thinking that this has gone on way too
long death and isaac I hope you yea just
coming over later won't see what what
happens then it's just she didn't like
that we just didn't have sex good that's
why we couldn't satisfy me because we
didn't have sex for updating man it
sucks men are to keep abreast to these
it's right you know you think you whip
out your boner and they just jump on it
no no life is not some adolescent
fantasy I know but I thought women have
this thing in their brain that like they
see a penis and then it just overshadows
all there's no they just have to done
something to the penis that's super
untrue many studies in just daily life
of showing an unsolicited dick can shut
down a lot of conversations very quickly
don't listen this guy Isaac and doesn't
nobody's talking about that show your
dick
nobody likes show your dick